kathy you said something beautiful about
how when writers
get feedback from you they feel safe
with the notes that you give them
how can someone deliver a message and
maybe
critique something but do it in a safe
way so that the people
can take it and change with it instead
of being wounded by it
well i think first of all you have to
try and understand
and find out from the writer what was
your intent
once you figure out what their intent
was
you try to work with that because you
you want their vision to shine through
their perspective of the situation that
they have put into their script
their um perspective of what the main
character is
who he is or who she is and what they're
about you want to make sure you don't
lose that
and so that's why when i give my notes i
do try to address that and keep those
things in mind
and i always tell them you know anything
that i say is not set in stone it really
is up to you because you're the one who
created
the project to make your decision on
what you think is best
i'm here to kind of give you guys an
idea of some of the things that
could possibly make it better or make it
stronger or make the character
more sympathetic so usually if i
phrase things in that way and if i look
at it that way they understand and i'm
not really like
attacking them and i'm not really so
much as making a judgment call it's
really trying to
give them another way of looking at a
a problem and how they might be able to
solve it
what's the first step in writing a
screenplay oh wow
having the idea and knowing how to
develop it
sometimes people will come to me and
they i've got a great idea
and i said well write it down oh no i
just want to tell
this i just want to pitch it to somebody
and have them write it into a movie and
get paid for the idea and i said
i hate to tell you but they don't pay
money for ideas
but once you have something written down
like a synopsis
of of your story where you have it well
you have most of the major details lined
up
all you have to do is register it with
the writer's guild if it's a screenplay
if it's a novel
um i think you know you need to you may
want to register with copyright people
or
or somebody like that you know just so
that you have a record of of having um
uh written it but you know you have to
write it down you can't just
expect somebody if you just tell them
the story you can't expect them to just
say okay yes here's
here's some money and i'd like to buy it
what do you think stops people from
writing it down i've heard that too oh i
have so many ideas they're up here
they're here you know what when you
write something
down on paper well first of all or what
it is nowadays is when you type it into
your computer
it's there it's and it's hard
it's it's um and then it's sometimes
painful to read it because you're not
quite sure
you know you have it down in your head
but is it going to translate well when
you read it
and it's almost two different things
because you have seen things visually
and you're trying to put all of it in
there so what's tough for writers i
think is sometimes
when writers do a whole script or a
whole novel or a whole manuscript
it's hard for them to try and focus when
they have to edit it
that's the hard hard process sometimes
they can get everything all written down
but then they don't understand that you
can't write everything down
and expect everybody to accept all of it
you have to pare it down so
the story is much clearer uh it's more
easy to understand
and also that do you have sympathetic
characters do you have dialogue that
rings
um true is there a message or a theme
that shines through and so all of those
things kind of come into play
if you were going to arm a screenwriter
with one tool or weapon as it relates to
writing
what would it be
that's a tough one i think there's i've
seen so many people who write
screenplays
the one thing that i think most writers
are scared most scared of besides
the writing process even more maybe than
the writing process
is the pitching process so
i would i would arm them with um
with the courage to be able to get out
there and to
sell themselves as well as to sell their
their project
to believe enough in your project that
you can go out there and can pitch it to
the world and let them know hey
this is my story this is who i am
and i would love the opportunity to have
you take a chance and read it
so the big day comes and they're there
to pitch what do they need to know
what preparation beforehand well
a lot of my clients what i have them do
is to have
certain tools one of them is of course
is a log line which i'm sure you guys
probably talked about before the other
is to
have a one-page pitch on paper which has
a summary
and it should be divided up into
hopefully three paragraphs which
mirror act one act two and act three and
those people
most people will use that as a leave
behind in case someone is interested but
they
wanna they don't wanna commit yet to
looking at the script so a lot of times
what they'll do is they'll
if they think someone's interested
they'll give them a pitch on paper
but when you're actually pitching one
thing that my clients use is something
called a pitch
outline a pitch outline
is uh very close
to what you want to want to say
but it's not all written down it's done
in little phrases
so that you're not tempted to read it
because when people start reading
their synopsis they lose their passion
they lose the excitement
the um the rhythm of the story because
they're busy staring down at their laps
trying to read the project and so their
commitment to the project doesn't always
show through
so with a pitch outline they have the
opportunity to be able to sort of if
when they need to
when they lose their way or if they want
to make sure that they're on track they
can glance down
if they see a phrase they know that that
what they have to do next is talk about
that particular area
so a pitch outline can be
used if you if you think about a trailer
of coming attractions all you have to do
is like
look at the trailer coming attractions
that's in the same genre as your project
and
you'll notice that it's three minutes
long most of them in that an area
and they usually focus on like five to
seven or eight
key highlights of the story
and that should jolt your memory well
maybe i
okay what can i think of in my storyline
that's similar to that
and those are the things that you should
be pitching and it basically should tell
us
who the main characters are what is the
the hero or heroines uh challenge
who or what stands in his way uh
what the what his or her mission or
journey is
and in a way if you can what the theme
is what is it that
that they learn at the end now in the
pitch you don't have to say
anything about you don't say and the
theme is you can just sort of allude to
it
but you do need to have um just a
general
uh an outline and it and it's not more
than maybe a half a page
three quarters of a page long but if you
like to i can
what i can do is i can uh for anyone
who's interested what i can do is i can
send you
an email you a copy of a pitch outline
for avatar
and you can share it with your listeners
so if you're interested let me know
self-awareness for writers
you know we always hear that great
writers we talked to
lee jessup and she said that
self-awareness is so important because
they need to know where they're lacking
and where they're strung
but how do we know who to ask and
where do we become more self-aware as a
writer
i think one of the ways you can become
more self-aware as a writer is to belong
to a writer's group
because i think the support that you get
from people who are going through some
of the same
uh challenges that you're going through
is inspiring to
to one you become a sounding board for
one another
and they did a study at harvard or yale
or one of those uh ivy league colleges
and they said the people the writers who
were in a writer's group
seemed to achieve success a lot faster
being in a writer's group than when
people
writers would do it alone so i do think
that
that's a good way of becoming having
achieving more of a self-awareness
and to be more confident about who you
are and what your work is about
another thing you might want to try
doing is is actually
consulting with people like like lee
jessup or
if there's anyone else that you that in
particular that you've
come carol kirschner is another good
really good one
these two people in general really focus
on helping to get your career started
and i think that once you take those
first few steps
with them things become so much easier
so
you know i i do similar things but most
of mine
uh really focuses on the business more
of the business end of screenwriting
the pitching the networking and and that
type of stuff so
you know uh i do think that there are
people out there that can help you with
it
lee is one person and and carol
kirschner is amazing too
networking for shy screenwriters
boyd it's um it's not easy
for a rider to break out of their shell
but i think that you can easily do it
once you
start thinking about what the end result
might be
and when you realize that there are
other people who are doing the same
thing that you're doing
it becomes easier and being in a
writer's group is one way another is to
do volunteer
or to be an intern there are several
it's just like
you know i met screenwriter i've been on
screenwriters
world i've done story expo great
american pitchers and these are all
wonderful opportunities to do volunteer
work
and you get to meet other speakers other
writers you get to talk with some of the
people who are listening to the pitches
who belong to production companies and
agencies
it's a wonderful way to network to build
your community of colleagues
and that's another way really of of
helping yourself to become more aware
of who you are and your work and that at
the same time
you're learning something in the process
because a lot of the volunteers i
noticed were sitting in
on some of the sessions and listening to
what we had to say and it was good to
see them there
and know that they were really you know
they were busily writing down
information and they were what was great
is when i would see them sharing it with
other
volunteers too